okay this is serious and this relates to
last night's debate we already talked
about the debate performance we talked
about Mike Bloomberg getting eaten alive
clearly didn't make his billions
debating that's for sure we talked about
the very clear divisions between the
progressives and the centrist during
last night's debate but we have to talk
about our democracy when we talk about
our system of democracy in the United
States we will often point out the flaws
of the electoral college system where
Republican presidents have frequently
lost the popular vote more people voted
for their opponent but yet they became
President of the United States 2016 and
Donald Trump is an example this happened
with George W Bush we've talked about
this before a similar dynamic exists in
the Democratic nomination process
wherein you can have a plurality of
pledged delegates going in to the
Democratic National Convention more
delegates than anybody else but you can
end up not being the nominee when
super-delegates typically party insiders
and elected officials get to vote on
this time in the second round of DNC
voting this came up at last night's
debate there was one person on the stage
who said I believe that whoever has the
most delegates should be the nominee
that was Bernie Sanders every other
candidate said we should follow the
system we should follow the rules of the
DNC take a look at this video and I want
to ask all of you this simple question
there's a very good chance of none of
you we're gonna have enough delegates to
the Democratic National Convention that
clinched this nomination okay if that
happens I want all of your opinions on
this should the person with the most
delegates at the end of this primary
season be the nominee even if they are
short of a majority
senator Sanders i'ma let you go last
year because I know your view on this
so instead I will start with you Mayor
Bloomberg whatever the rules of the
Democratic Party are they should be
followed and if they have a process
which I believe I do
everybody conditions and you want the
convention to work its will yes senator
Ward Convention working as will means
that people have the delegates that are
pledged to them and they keep those
delegates yes or no leading person with
the delegates should they be the nominee
or not no let the process work its way
out mayor Buda judge not necessarily not
till the senator klobuchar let the
process work standard Sanders well the
process includes 500 super-delegates on
the second ballot so I think that the
will of the people this is not a trivial
issue not only because it goes to the
core of what does it mean to reflect the
will of the people but this is not a
trivial issue because this is
increasingly likely to be the scenario
we already know that if Bernie keeps
getting 25 or 30 percent of the vote in
primaries he likely will not have 50
percent of the delegates the way the
math works you can get 50 percent of the
delegates without 50 percent of the vote
we did this yesterday if you are in the
35 to 38 percent of the vote depending
on how many viable candidates there are
that is enough to get 50 percent of the
delegates but if Bernie stays around 28
to 31 it's very likely he won't get 1991
delegates case in point the
fivethirtyeight.com estimate right now
says that the most likely scenario is
one in which nobody gets to 50% plus one
of the delegates there's a 40%
probability of that Bernie getting 50%
plus one has a 37% probability no other
scenario gets past 11% now the DNC
increasingly knows this the candidates
on the stage increasingly know this and
this is the strategy to deny Bernie the
nomination so what every candidate on
that stage is saying is I don't think
that if you enter the convention with
the most delegates you
should be the nominee they are saying no
matter who gets the most delegates
super-delegates should have their say
and the DNC's completely flawed process
is what gets to decide and by the way
what they're also sort of saying is and
I hope you'll pick me when that time
comes Bernie is saying the will of the
people should determine who the nominee
is it's very simple nobody else is
saying that on the stage and what this
certainly reveals is that the candidates
themselves are all but conceding Bernie
will get the most delegates but it's a
bold-faced attempt to try to sort of
cross their fingers say I stand by the
system I'm in line and hope that the DNC
will pick them to be the nominees when
Bernie fails to get to 1991 delegates
now I've been consistent on this from
day one this is not about any individual
candidates policy I don't think we
should have an electoral college system
nationally and I don't think we should
have a delegate system for the
nomination that includes super-delegates
at any point in time now at the national
level we can get around the electoral
college without a big constitutional
amendment through something called the
national popular vote interstate compact
and what that the way that works is if
enough states say we will give our
electors to whoever wins the popular
vote if enough states such that their
total number of electoral votes totals
270 without changing the Constitution
you have a de facto national popular
vote we know the path to that nationally
for the DNC system to change the DNC
needs to agree to change it why would
they do that when this is how they
retain some degree of control over who
the nominee is regardless of the will of
the people it's an uphill battle for
sure this was a very telling moment from
last night's debate and one that without
a doubt is going to be consequential in
terms of who ultimately is the nominee
and something we're going to be watching
very closely in terms of numbers as the
delegates start to be apportioned on the
basis of voting let's take a quick break
make
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show if you
watch the david pakman show you should
check out a youtube channel we're
partnering with called up flip click the
link right underneath this video it'll
take you to their channel while you're
there make sure to subscribe and click
that bell for notifications up flip is a
channel perfect for anyone like me who's
fascinated with small businesses and
entrepreneurs and what makes them tick
and every Wednesday up flip uploads a
new video where they interview an
entrepreneur they give you an inside
look at how the business works what
makes the business successful what a day
in their shoes is really like if you
enjoy shows like Shark Tank I think
you'll really like this channel and
again the channel is called up flip
they're friends of the David Pakman show
I'd love it if people in my audience
subscribe to their channel click the
bell so that you get updates about their
videos and I've put a link right below
that will take you directly to their
YouTube channel check it out